hey guys you know what I hate hey we
have the same shirt
yeah it's called mass production but
even more than that I hate how many
options we have when it comes to how we
look it's like when you go to a
restaurant with like a really impossible
menu and yours overwhelmed by how much
crap there is every month I feel like I
need some grand makeover but really when
you think about it there are a million
different ways you could present
yourself I mean this is much different
than this why would you whistle I
probably spent like five hours yesterday
looking up face shades and what's the
best hairstyle for my face shape what
kind of lenses and how to do my makeup I
cannot count the hours that I have
wasted trying to figure out if this is
the optimum Anna can I get any better
looking than this is there some way that
I can be more here in this area don't
lie I know you've done it too oh my god
what the fuck is that
um it's Hello Kitty dumb get it around
ever come on but no matter what you do
to your parents just remember
it's what's inside that counts and every
time I look in the mirror I remind
myself of that you look fucking fine
dancing Gotham